because you're a leading lady people are
constantly probably telling you what to
do and what not to do to not affect your
career people say don't be photographed
with a girlfriend I used to have
conversations where people would be like
if you don't want to talk about it and
you don't want to define yourself then
you need to stop setting yourself up for
that by going out and whatever and it
was just like well here's the thing now
that question is it's a ridiculous and
ignorant question and it's a sort of
like violent yes like okay a friend of
mine has a kid and she was like hey I
asked my kid if he was like Gabe it was
like in like the nicest like sort of
most I was just curious I just want to
know him I just want to be as close to
him as I possibly can and he's really
young and he is really self possessed
and very clearly already feels
comfortable in a way that feels fluid
and cool and kind of like you don't know
where it's gonna go and he was like this
is child abuse and I was like it's true
it's like you know on some level of the
the sort of fervent question that was
demanded of me for so long is now
ridiculous that's true it's it's a
non-starter but that's a Hollywood thing
I remember the days yeah Rock Hudson was
a gay man there's a couple of guys in
Hollywood who are leading men who were
gay but if the Pajero public found out
you were [ __ ] right no one could
accept you in a heterosexual role like
you're an actor you're pretending to be
something what's the difference but yet
society hadn't gotten there I am so
coincidentally lucky it to be like
living in in this time and I look at
literally just like kids people five
years younger than me have it so much
easier than I did three years ago like
it was just like it was just this
ridiculous no reason why anyone needs to
like provide an easy narrative for other
people to digest it's like there's no
why why would I simplify something very
complex just in order for you to feel
comfy it's like no I want to diminish
this like cool thing which is like
discovering yourself and your sexuality
and like how that changes like yeah yeah
I actually really do admire your courage
because I'm old enough to remember how
horrible it was when people would come
out
and especially in Hollywood oh man and I
wait the way you live in your life is a
beautiful example you were like hey [ __ ]
it I coming off Twilight I can I can do
movies I can do this but I'm not gonna
sit I would enjoy holding the person I
loves hand in public yeah